sono claudio spadoni executive producer
di rocchi mille ovvero il realizzatore
di quello che avete appena visto
stasera potrei sicuramente raccontarvi
di quanto è importante credere in un
progetto per realizzarlo di quanto
importante metterci dedizione impegno
passione però quello che vorrei
condividere con voi in realtà è una
sensazione è la sensazione che ho
provato quando fabio mi ha raccontato la
sua idea è una chiesto di realizzarla ed
è stata una sensazione di totale panico
e proprio paura e vertigini e l'unico
modo per superare questo momento è stato
quello di guardare la sfida che lui
stava ponendo davanti di metterla un po
più lontano ancora un po e scoprire che
questa sfida è composta da tante altre
sfide da tante parti ognuna delle quali
s'è portata a termine può realizzare
quello che volevamo fare
ed è così che abbiamo fatto anche con
rocchi mille siamo andati ad individuare
quattro miracoli li abbiamo chiamati
così tutti dedicati a dave grohl e
questi quattro miracoli erano quelle di
raccogliere 40 mila euro partendo da
nulla coinvolgere mille musicisti farle
suonare insieme realizzare un video e
convincere in questo modo i foo fighters
a venire a suonare al suo sera
semplicissimo la prima cosa che abbiamo
fatto per
quindi per andare a mettere in fila
questa serie è stata quella di creare un
team cioè quindi un insieme di persone
ognuna mossa dalle proprie per
motivazioni che andavano a svolgere a
incaricarsi di un di un'impresa c'erano
varie imprese ovviamente dobbiamo creare
una piattaforma mai fatta prima che
permettesse di reclutare selezionare e
gestire mille musicisti dovevamo creare
un progetto di sonorizzazione mai fatto
raccogliere questi 40 mila euro senza
aver nessun tipo di credibilità e quindi
con un progetto di crowdfunding è
un'operazione commerciale di più solita
creare un sistema di comunicazione che
andasse a comunicare non soltanto con il
pubblico ma con i musicisti e li
vincesse a venire a suonare con noi e
anche per i donatori e di tutto questo
realizzare un video incredibile che
lasciasse senza parole tanto da
convincere i foo fighters a venire a
suonare fondamentali per queste imprese
erano sicuramente i mille ovvero
dovevamo far sì che il sogno di uno
diventasse il sogno di mille e far sì
che mille musicisti per partissero da
casa loro con il loro strumento e
venissero a suonare al parco ippodromo
di cesena
cosa che hanno fatto come abbiamo appena
visto il 24 luglio del 2015
il 30 luglio il video di questa
performance era online
dopo 10 ore contava 4 milioni di
visualizzazioni
oggi conta 45 milioni
la stampa di tutto il mondo ha parlato
di questo di questo video di questa
impresa
il giorno dopo fabio
in videoconferenza con la sia nell ne ha
parlato al jazeera qualunque rivista
musicale rolling stone italia si
chiedeva se veramente i foo fighters e
sarebbero venuti a mangiare la cretina
romagnola e anche dentro il b del suo
video ciao cesena sono davide ciao mi
dispiace un po italiano sono un po un po
questo video
ma che bello che bellissimo
grazie mille stiamo arrivando
prometto ci vediamo presto
grazie mille ti amo in effetti il 4
novembre del 2015
i foo fighters sono venuti a suonare al
cesena in questa foto è fabio che fa
stage diving il pubblico fino ad
arrivare al palco succede che quando si
perseguono idea e si affronta una sfida
si attiva e si crea un circolo virtuoso
il cui processo non si poteva immaginare
quando si è cominciato e forse proprio
per questo consiglierei sempre di
affrontare una sfida e questo ci è
successo anche in questo caso nel senso
che le energie che si sono mosse
in questa giornata è cosa semplice
semplice giornata le persone che mi
hanno partecipato e tutte le azioni che
si sono messe in moto a un fatto sì che
nascesse un qualcosa che prima non
esisteva una vera e propria
contaminazione per positiva per
definizione e questa cosa è la più
grande band del mondo quindi quel giorno
è nata la piu grande e ben nel mondo e
questa band è caratterizzata da passione
ovvero dalla passione per far musica di
mille musicisti che si incontrano in uno
stadio suonano davanti a un pubblico è
un esempio di condivisione questi mille
musicisti si condividono un sogno se lo
taton addosso e lasciano la rete dove
interagiscono fra loro e si incontrano
in un campo da calcio dove suona non a
fianco all'altro è un esempio di
integrazione in quanto questi musicisti
sono mille persone di differenti età
sesso provenienza sociale religiose
rascal e probabilmente anche politica
che però suonando uno affianco all'altro
mandano un chiarissimo messaggio che è
quello che uniti si può fare qualcosa di
più grande e così che cos'è questa come
possiamo definire tutto ciò se non
contaminazione positiva un rock i mille
e oggi si rinnova di anno in anno quindi
nel tempo nello spazio e anche nel mondo
cercando di basare la sua forza nel
nell'essere
nell'essere nel basarsi su scusate mi
sono emozionata nel raccontarmi nella
fiducia sulla base della sua forza sulla
fiducia sul fidarsi di se stessi e
fidarsi degli altri che ci stanno
accanto
andando ad individuare dei limiti ma non
vedendo in questi limiti delle barriere
ma anzi delle opportunità da cogliere e
quindi individuando di volta in volta un
traguardo possibilmente impossibile da
andare a superare e ve lo auguro a tutti
grazie
[Applauso]